what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the channel
tori
hello everybody
how is everybody
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos also
all super chats will be read and all
donations will be going towards the
sound board so i can host eight hot
girls
in my apartment okay you know i can't
promise they'll all be hot but they'll
be at least sixes
men have a low attraction floor
okay they're all hot
they're all hot
how many things do you have
what
how many um mic setups do you have right
now
um
i have
four for the soundboard
and then um i have one more mic but it's
like a music mic so it's too sensitive
i'm going to sell it and then buy which
one
i love this stuff
it's so good
you should auction it
wait hold on
which brand is that
okay wait
you know what you could do is you could
put well i don't did you start the show
yeah i did but it doesn't matter because
um
you should get the rode wireless if you
want that many [ __ ]
really the rode wireless yeah i use it
when i game
huh should we pull it up let's see how
good it sounds
throwback clip why not as you guys know
we don't always stay on topic
wireless mic
so i can get these for all the girls
so you know when you see people
oh [ __ ] i was opening ecam [ __ ]
no look at you can see here
no because i have i have one of these
actually what tap am i in
i can bluetooth them
you're you're on the side i just shared
my screen
yeah i don't know where the hell okay do
you think that's better than the this
like mics like this
oh i'm staring i oh there you are okay
um
whoa
this looks like inception here look at
it no this is i'm sure yeah that's it so
they just came out with um
a new one go to the actual website
they're awesome because okay the episode
i did with um
paul
benjamin shout out apex mindset
i texted tony and i was like hey can we
do the wireless mics just because i
don't want to have to do the whole setup
and
um you kind of just talk as if you're
talking in a room
the one thing that
we forgot to do
um i forget what it's called something i
it probably has to do with condensing or
compressing so it sounded a lot like i
was cutting him off and cutting him off
but
when you hook up the thing i'm thinking
of it actually works equivalent to like
the share
so okay you're on the website go to new
is there like a new tab
oh you're just on the wireless go okay
yeah how much are they
like 179
pounds so probably like 200 something us
dollars they should be like 250 i think
yeah that's about right because it's
like a 25 conversion rate oh okay okay
yeah no they're awesome though because
you just set them up and then you clip
the thing on like your shirts kind of
like a t-shirt mic but it's better and
you can go
two places they're wireless so if you
guys wanted to do an episode where you
go try to pick up people on the street
instead of getting all this gear i'm
saying that's like stationary
you can kind of mix it up so that if you
wanted to do other stuff with it
because it sounds
well it's up to you i'm sending you no
black no
no i'm i'm open to it i'm not i'm not
married to any equipment
i need equipment
really you'll learn to love it i hate
this stuff um
can i hook up that stuff to
like
because like when it hooks up to a
camera doesn't it
so
the how many cameras do you have when
you film
just one right now because like i can't
really
so you have the adapter thing this is
where i used to get confused to keep the
camera running right so it hooks up to
your laptop or your monitor and then it
all have usually two
things it has like a usb
connector and then it has
like the new iphone connectors and then
it has the actual wireless into the wall
which
if you want to shoot in 4k hooking that
up is the best however
um
like i have the adapter for it but this
wireless connector is different
i got a cheaper one but
the only the reason why you're plugging
in your camera is so that your audio on
the road caster
syncs with the video photo yeah yes yes
otherwise it's a [ __ ]
i tried to do it it's horrible
so
you're saying that you would have to
hook up are you confused that you have
to hook up multiple
hubs or something
i just don't know where like could i
hook up like would i hook up the
the equipment you're showing me
to the soundboard
that i literally know exactly where you
are in your equipment process thinking
like this is so me
um yes it's bluetooth
oh okay that's where the bluetooth it's
okay it's cool yeah but it's wireless so
what will happen is on your computer i
could use a fifth mic on on could it
host five then because i could plug in
the four and then bluetooth yeah
you could technically add on as many as
you want it's really
yeah but you it's probably better to
have somebody live that can monitor the
voice levels
so you know like fresh and fit they have
like a road caster that's um they
probably have the apex i don't know it's
it's a really long one it's like twelve
hundred dollars and you can hook up i
believe it's like
24 something like that
but if you were on a budget what you
would do is get the road caster and then
either t-shirt mics hooked up to another
phone or camera or you do the wireless
where you don't need another camera
huh
yeah
but the problem is you need a live
studio
person that you can save money i need to
find one maybe i should
you could teach somebody
somebody that wants to be around a bunch
of girls it's really easy once you get
the hang of it
huh because you hear it
they wear headphones yeah yeah
interesting or you can mute their mics
well i know
there's a couple people here that are
interested in this stuff
um
not guys but like girls
um
i'd just be curious to see how much time
they'd be willing to do it for because i
can't pay them clearly
what are the schools like out there like
i would try to find somebody who wants
to
go into broadcasting that's willing to
put in a few hours so they can put it on
their resume like a kid
i don't know if that's illegal
if you're making money it might be but i
don't know
it's not not much
i want to see can we are there people in
the chat oh i see you okay
hey yeah uh there's actually 20 people
where i was like what up what up
everybody um okay well let's let's talk
about the egg
yeah
go ahead
so you said you've never had an egg
is that true do you know what the egg is
i do but the situation where i had the
egg it's a it's a little
um
heavy
red pill
theory
go ahead tell me right before
um
i
cheated
yeah oh no
um so
i think what happens is when you meet
somebody that you deem better than your
partner i was 21 i think
um this was the guy that i no matter how
i broke up with him i couldn't get rid
of him
and he had the egg too i have heard that
from a lot of girls
so and i try to break up with someone
and they like won't go away so they
cheat i've heard that a lot actually
yeah i think he had bpd we've talked
about it after the fact um his dad
passed away and a lot of people kind of
just dipped out of his life so i think
he has abandonment issues okay but he
he's with this beautiful girl that's a
doctor in poland they're both polish
like karma
worked
for him
like he's got some good [ __ ] going but
um i remember having
this actually there's a thing called
uh
repulsion syndrome do you know that
yeah
hold on let me see what the definition
is because that's the only time i can
think of a moment where i had already
met like an alpha guy and the guy i was
with
repulsed me
no offense if you ever watch my videos
it has
okay
what do you mean republic what did he do
that was so repulsing
he wouldn't let me leave like he oh you
know what he cried there you go don't
cry that's what it was
okay he like held on to my leg
like this
you know what i'm talking about
yeah no i could see it that's never
happened to me but oh my god
yeah i had really bad ptsd at the time
not because of him but like i was not
fully um
i was horrible
but i was just not present
so what about you
the egg i get the egg can you hear me
mm-hmm okay okay um i get the ick all
the
time like it'll be like i'm starting an
alpha widowed
and we're like beta widow
you never know
no it's like
you'll be starting to like a guy like
you're kind of trying to decide if
you're attracted to him or not
because everyone what ways what would
you ask
let's break this down baby like this
video if you haven't liked it yet i'm a
slow person so like like
no not like that
like like i it takes me a long time to
like feel comfortable with someone
how long
it's not about how many times you have
to meet them
oh god a lot that's my problem um
yeah if i um
if i just meet
like most of the
guys that i've slept with were like guy
friends that like
yeah like guy friends to be honest
that i ended up like liking and like
wanting to date usually
how did what made you change your mind
what it wasn't like it wasn't like i
changed my mind it's just like you spent
more time with them yeah it's like the
amount of time you like the
my last boyfriend i probably slept with
like the quickest
um
but
it was just because like we both were
unemployed
so like we both were doing youtube so we
could hang out together all the time so
it was like
the number of hours we spent together
does that make sense no it does because
if you're somebody who's more
like
if you're a guy that's high value you're
probably not going to see a girl you
just start dating like maybe once a week
so sometimes when you're in the same
industry
you can double the frequency that you
see them so obviously something could
happen i say that yeah so it's more like
the number that's why online dating
doesn't really work well for me because
like i just feel like you're a complete
stranger you could be anyone yeah
so
it
like it would take less time if we had
like mutual friends or like i knew you
know what i mean that's typically the
way people get married is through mutual
friends i don't know if that's changed
yet
no it's like i think 30 of marriages
come from online dating
i also brought a statistic i don't know
if this is like a buzzfeed statistic i
haven't looked into it but um
it was like
not a hundred but in the 90s i can't
remember what percent of relationships
that met online fail within the first
year that makes sense i think like the
out is easier than with community
the what the out so like
if you're dating someone in your friend
group like the cost is higher i've read
that before yeah then like yeah if you
guys have intertwined social groups it's
like you have to think a little more
before you leave you've totally read
this before yeah where if it's someone
online
it's like you just never that's true
but i don't know like guys will just do
certain things like what
like trying to get physical too fast
that gives me a really big
yeah that like if they push it like if i
if i say no they keep like they're pushy
yeah i i get such an egg yeah i totally
know what you mean what if they don't do
it at all
that's better you've got to find a happy
medium if they don't do it at all
it actually like
kind of works better for them in my
opinion because i'm like the girl starts
to want to do it at some point
almost putting her in the friend zone
first
or assuming like pretending you are
yeah yeah well
not even that but just like
so i think of again like my last
boyfriend um
he
he was just like that was one of the
things that made me really like him was
i just told him
like i take that stuff slow and he just
doesn't push he like at all he's like
okay no problem it was like no big deal
yeah that's so good yeah
yeah
um
well what what is giving you the ick
um
so crying yeah other than the crying
uh
i mean the obvious
you know treating a waiter poorly
not being able to handle your alcohol
that's a god that's a huge air yeah as a
bartender
you see so many and those are the ones
that they have
not judge in okay guys
i've seen a lot of guys get clean
throughout my bartending career so that
i mean that's not that long of a time
it's like six or seven years so but
there's something about a man that
cannot
it's worse than a drunk girl screaming
profanity because drunk girls you can
kind of level with them sometimes
but men
it's that you can't and it could result
in
which i'm not against physical violence
but like cop situations where you can
get like the police called on you i've
gotten scared where a guy got too drunk
like he didn't do anything but like it's
like as a woman
no especially because i don't drink now
yeah so if it's just like
like if you guys are on a date or
something and he's acting like super dr
it kind of scares you a little bit for
me at least i it just depends
i don't know because i've i'm friends
with a lot of industry people and we're
kind of known for
drinking
not so much anymore but right before
shifts and stuff like we would get
really drunk but we could handle it
because we'd be working i don't know why
that is but probably because
you count to five and put the mixer in
so the guys i know
can really handle their liquor are
probably not the best to compare them to
if that makes sense
i don't know other than that
uh
ich
i'm thinking
i've dated great men
i just don't know
um
pleasing you all the time
and not in the way that people think i
mean they constantly ask what you need
i'm like i'm [ __ ] fine
like i'm fine but they'll be like do you
want something to eat do you want this
do you want that and i'm just like no
leave me alone
that was the same guy
i feel bad but
no
if i ever
it's never happened to me i don't think
i mean it's a really complicated
situation
always asking me what i need
like literally i mean granted i was
going through some [ __ ]
so to some people it might have been
endearing but the stuff that i needed at
the time
he couldn't provide
but he would say he could
so like
if i was in a life or death situation
and i call you because i can't drive and
i'm in a forest
this is a true story yeah and you tell
me you can pick me up and my phone's
about to die and you show up four hours
later
you're a piece of [ __ ]
i don't know
yeah
so like didn't show up in the areas
where i was like scared for my life i
guess
it's complicated because i don't speak
about that stuff yet
but other than that it's like
i guess that would be when a guy just
doesn't get it
i don't know because when i think of x
most of the ics i've gotten are on like
first dates where like i find him what i
don't do that you don't do dates no they
like come to my work
for a while before i go out with them
so that's never so when i met all your
boyfriends
yeah
huh
yeah that's actually that's actually
great because you kind of have to do
stuff yeah
yeah it starts off with me being i'm
like the [ __ ] bartender but i'm very
friendly but like i'll joke with people
i'm really outgoing and entertaining so
it lets guys
they're like free to be themselves
there's like nothing to really i don't
know
no i could see it because that's almost
like the friend route in a way
because you have to get to know them
first before you can even go on a date
yeah yeah yeah like in a way just you
know i like won't know what they do for
a living i know that when i do end up
going out with them i'm like so
what you do for a living i hate asking
that
i like like we know each other on a i
know you like tequila i've seen you
spill over a blue drink on a girl like
and that's the level i know them at so
it's weird have you ever seen them like
take home other girls and then you went
on a date with them
like you dated them okay was that weird
at all i don't know if you've noticed
noticed but yeah they always leave with
girls i'm a great wingman
social proof
but why would that bother me i don't
care i won't do that but
that makes you calmer around me it's
better
no it's almost just i don't know that'd
be like kind of awkward
why
i'm always prettier than them
i don't care
actually that's what someone this
because
this guy asked me on a date he said um
do you
he's like do you get jealous about like
female friends and i said it depends how
hot they are
really
yeah
like if if there's it depends like you
don't want a guy having a girl that like
friend zoned him and he's just like
still simping for her
wait okay
repeat the last part wait you don't it's
like it depends how hot she is yeah
i don't get it
okay you lost me
so if the guy
he asked me like do i get jealous about
like girls yeah female like other girls
like if he had female friends oh like
his females and i said yeah and i said
uh well it depends how hot they are i
guess because really
yeah
like because you know what
you've never seen that guy that's like
still something for the girl he actually
wants but like with his girlfriend
um i don't know i've dated guys that are
really
high iq
very um
arguably
like on the spectrum probably not but
like that level so for me it's like
a little bit different i guess and the
girls also married and
now she's having a baby there was only
one instance and i always
he was always providing for me
emotionally and all that stuff so i
never really questioned it
yeah i've actually i've never even been
in that situation to be honest
oh okay yeah i know that's never
happened to me but that's just that's
how i would think about it
i would assume the guy isn't really
leveling up and when i say that i mean
to your needs
because when he gives you your needs you
don't question [ __ ]
when they don't that's when the phone
thing goes off you're like i want to
check his phone that's your thing
when he
oh
the when he oh when you're saying when
he doesn't um
meet like your needs that's when you get
like the egg
sort of or like that's when your
intuition kind of goes off
no i was saying like
girls that go through phones and stuff
if the guy
there's usually a reason for it
and it's either
the guy
is in some way shape or form deemed
himself unsafe to her so you could say
that oh that's interesting actually okay
yeah
yeah there's like some level of security
that's not there the biggest fear women
have is that the guy's not gonna be the
guy he says he is that's why tinder
swindler dude really [ __ ] blew up
that's so interesting that's really i've
never thought about it that way
but that's really true because that kind
of matches what i was saying earlier
with like i kind of have to like wait
and see to like know who you are yeah
people operate the same way as me with
the betas we go for the provisioning
first
[Laughter]
protection provisioning some other
i don't think that's a thing i think it
just means that
we didn't have that much fun
i think that's all that is
i can't
think of a guy that i was like i wanna
bang you
never
it's never been a thought
what about for you
yeah but the guys like that i i
typically kind of avoid because i'm like
i'd never get
like commitment from them did you watch
me in paul's episode oh my god no
you have to watch it
what is it what episode
uh
[ __ ] what i call it
just look up torsha and
apex mindset paul
um he was explaining that
it's safe to go for [ __ ] boys sometimes
but in some way i deem them unsafe
no i do like
mom well because my type is like
basketball players but
i kind of
avoid them because yeah
that's a belief
paradigm
well it's not really a
i mean i don't want to say
it's it's true basketball players like
how to sleep with everybody you know
i don't know i don't date athletes i
don't know yeah well i mean i'm just
around athletes all the time
so
it's kind of like
the going for an nba player you need
like the legacy component
that survived the guy that stays
faithful no matter what doesn't leave
you when you're
old
yeah i don't know family is just really
important to me and i just i had a
really good like dad as a role model
so
i don't know it's
that's why i like the guys that i would
say you have the
the ick with
no i was gonna say like the genuine like
desire like they're so attractive i'm
kind of like they would never be
faithful you know
yeah apparently some of them are
it's a false belief system that we have
oh come on nba i'm dead nba players well
does he have to be in the nba well we're
going to go to the extreme because
that's how you can kind of touch imagine
the life you could have in the babies
you could have they'd be like child
prodigies
i don't care if he's banging it out with
some ugly batch once in a while come on
think about the jeans no no i couldn't
so you'd rather well that's an extreme
if i'm like so you'd rather a [ __ ]
i mean not a [ __ ] i
like
i don't know i don't know if i was tall
like you and i was in sports i probably
would consider it
it's just an idea
no i'm good
you're like
it's my dad's okay my dad's approval is
literally everything to me that is what
i care about it's like my dad approving
of like the things i do
and
that's
what you're your own person i know i am
but it's like really important to me
that my dad approves of the guy i'm with
well yeah
so
i would never i would never like to me
that's so disrespectful like to my dad
to like accept that from someone when he
never did it when he could have
but how do you know they're going to
oh i don't for sure but
i'm just saying you got to be like
cautious especially as a girl like you
can get one std
and not have kids
true
like
true
that i guess if they're in like i was
gonna say how often are they getting
laid and it's like nba players i know
the girls at the club that work at the
club would always go out with them after
and stuff
yeah i don't know if they were thoughts
though
science
it's just an idea
yeah i'm good who knows if you meet one
that's like a super christian boy
virgin
i mean if it happened but i don't know i
have a really
i don't know it's like they haven't been
having sex a lot of them are losing
their virginity later you might have a
chance
i don't know i think
so
pick a guy early but you won't do that
either
am i not am i early or no 25 is that
late
sometimes i see red pellets like over 25
it's over with
who cares you know it's it's your own
time i think covet kind of pushed it
back
not saying that i mean if you want
babies it should definitely be at the
forefront of your brain
yeah
but i don't believe in
um
kids before marriage
oh no that's why i'm so big on marriage
is because the way that it was developed
back in the day was specifically to keep
the father involved because it arguably
the father is the most important and
he's the easily
he's like
the least attached compared to all of
them
what i mean by that in hierarchy needs
or hierarchy standards it's like the
mom's always going to be attached to the
kid always the kid came out of her and
then the kid is like attached to puppies
or something and the dad is
loosely attached marriage keeps them
attached
and that that component really changes
the way that kids grow up so
that's the only reason why
i believe in marriage but other than
that if i didn't want kids i probably
wouldn't get married
i don't know definitely gotta find a
husband like tomorrow
tomorrow are you looking
no
pearl i haven't done [ __ ] like i haven't
done [ __ ] i'm in here
all day
no i i know but are you gonna start
looking
it's like i'm i have an apathy for it
right now so i don't know what's an
apathy like i'm
not
i'm just on
i'm not overly excited to it just
mentally i'm not
are you not over i think you're just
trying
is it like your last breakup
no no no no no i just really enjoy my
alone time i don't think i have enough
time to give somebody else right now
yeah that's how i feel actually and i'm
poor
and i just
i don't know
i don't really understand how i'm
supposed to go for a guy that embodies
these alpha traits that every guy on the
manosphere keeps telling me i have to go
for i just don't
understand
like well i obviously
there's something that
is missing adam's available
your brother
my brother's a [ __ ] dick
he's hilarious
mother is the best person i know he
knows people
he pushed a kid in a wheelchair growing
up in marathons
that's [ __ ]
okay
i'll go out with him
he was like a good traitor
yeah
no every time i need help adam when i
was like sad because i was like really
depressed right after like i that
breakup and stuff it was like mentally
unstable for a hot minute
um but adam was the one who like called
me every night and like yeah he's like
actually really nice he's a jerk though
but yeah he's really nice
i i like to hear the nice things
yeah well it's like he's like
he's rough you know what i mean so like
he's like boy he's rude yeah
so like you kind of have to get past
that but he's actually like really nice
i don't like men that don't adore me
that's like one thing
i was always trying to hook adam up with
someone i am i want i want nieces and
nephews like yesterday
related
oh my god my kid would be your genetics
yeah
imagine pushing out the shoulders dude
like
imagine how tall this thing would be
i don't know y'all are
too tall
terrify me i'd give birth to like a
man-child
a kid
you can't
so i'm like i'm shocked though you've
never really had x because i've had guys
that i genuinely like they do one thing
and i'm like i just can't anymore but
you haven't really gone on a ton of
first
dates like did you not have multiple
guys ask you out from the club and like
get no i go all in baby
really
yeah don't do that [ __ ]
i probably should have been spinning
plates because i'm learning that guys
automatically assume you are
i'm like nope i love love
here
it just depends where i meet the guy but
yeah
i'm too scared to go on first dates
pearl i
like let's go get dinner can we not
oh no you have to do
something you can leave yeah
coffee and i drive
yeah that's no that's literally what i
do oh yeah if i drank i would do a drink
yeah i'm like already getting nervous
it's like giving me anxiety right now
just a thought
yeah i've all the people i've met have
been very organic too like what am i
supposed to do go like i have that
tinder thing so i can [ __ ] use
people's profiles for this episode
series but i haven't been on it since
a couple weeks ago
yeah i opened it once and it was like
over 99 hearts or something i was like
this is too much and i don't like it
because they also don't pick you they're
just swiping
oh well duh
but that like i already hate you
and i'll never get over the fact that
you were on a dating app and i've talked
about this
that in the back of a woman's mind if
she met you on a dating app she will
always
just assume that you are some form of a
creep even though a woman's on the app
think about it
um
sit with it sit with it
i don't feel like that to be honest like
if i
what if you found him on ashley madison
after him or married i know it
no i mean it just depends i just think
you're desperate like they'll forget i
just have to see your like normal so
like
can i like
do you have friends and like social you
know like
like because if i'm eating up a dating
app like my first thought is like are
you weird
are you like i'm weird
it's not bad
no not like that like creepy
okay
break it down
are you gonna win
are you gonna kill me oh yeah
because first of all i'm always nervous
okay i listen to the crime podcasts a
lot
are you trained
i'm not at all i would be a sitting duck
let me teach you some [ __ ] right now
this is good
if a man ever
comes up from behind and bear hugs you
or from the front go limp okay this
doubles your body weight it's like
trying to drag a dead body and then
count to a couple seconds because
they'll be like what the [ __ ] should you
just win them and then you roll out of
it it works i've had people that
actually try to
um there's some sp uh what do you call
it
uh trainers that will like kind of let
you go
no i was literally like being choked to
death i was like i'm literally gonna die
right now and then i went limp that was
one thing i've learned another thing is
the wrist twist that one's hard if they
have a gun i've had a gun held up to my
head so this one speaks volumes to me
oh my god you've lived very different
i'm chilling i'm having a great time to
be honest
i've gone through some serious [ __ ]
though
the barrel was damned i could see it
it was like all [ __ ]
who held like an ex-boyfriend
oh what
no
a stranger
um he asked me for
a lighter handed m1 and then there i was
up against a brick wall and that's what
made me not like men for a while because
there were so many
security guards outside men that were
coming out of the club and they did
nothing
so i was just like ah granted there's a
gun so but
uh another thing that i've learned
my mom used to always say if you get put
in the trunk
do this to the light but now we have new
cars so i don't um
oh what would you do
i was in a trunk i would just fall in
love with them i feel like would you
pick me
i think i would just literally like
kick and scream like i would just
be a menace
yeah i'm not saying it'd be effective
but i just see myself having like a
major temper tantrum and just being as
loud as humanly possible and hoping
against someone's attention that would
be my plan
yeah it's scary to think about because i
heard um
like it was
they asked like people that have
sexually assaulted someone like how they
pick their victims and they would say
that if a woman puts up too much of a
fight they'll just let her go because
like it's true yeah that's that would be
my plan
a lot of times um
it's at hours it's like late at night
and there's another car involved what
would you do
this is fun
um okay late at night
yeah
i can get out of a rope tie so i'm
confident even if i was put up against
her chair wouldn't people still hear me
scream
no what if they taped your mouth
carry a whistle [ __ ] they give us a
whistle
[ __ ] works though
i'd probably be dead yeah i'd probably
be
honestly i just always hope they'll go
for a shorter victim no offense um
like why on earth if you were a
kidnapper would you pick the six foot
athlete
manatees or whatever that thing is where
they like i would go for the
you respectfully but like the short
i can get out of a lot of teeth oh i've
gone through a lot of training
yeah
i mean look i'm not maybe i would be the
right victim to pick but they don't know
that
they might now because i'm saying it on
the internet but
i got mad hops like i'm i'm getting out
you're trying to go like i would just
i'm loud i would be as loud as humanly
possible
oh my god well what would you say
i would just scream
have you ever been blindfolded and put
in the trunk of the car for fun
no really
oh my god
you left
okay we're gonna do this i'm gonna put
you in the trunk of my car and i'm gonna
drive and you're gonna have to tell me
where where we are based on
what turns you think i made you need to
know that oh my gosh i know
do you know what my friend gabby is
very um
i put it
tough let's just say like she would
i she would mess someone up right yeah
and
we had a funny video idea where she
teaches me how to hit someone
do not know how
no because she i did it once for her and
she's like that is the weakest hit i
have ever seen in my life
take this part of your hand and go right
up to their ear and it will ring if you
do it loud enough it's really
disinhibiting
it's pretty bad
you could do the balls too but i have a
level of respect i'm just kidding
i had on heels at the time so i was like
thank god
oh my gosh this is why i just
you know what statistically it probably
won't happen to me so yeah
hopefully
i'm putting you in my trunk i think this
will be fun
sometimes i want a boyfriend for safety
purposes
who is he protecting you from
well i just live alone so it's like
yeah i saw that once and i was like
that was a good argument like
yeah but if i was a kid i don't know i
always think of what i would do if i was
a kidnapper like in a normal way you
know smart i'm like why would i pick
what like you would pick the girl that's
by herself not with a guy
yeah absolutely yeah that's why
i live in a pretty safe building though
so i'm like lucky but
what if they grab the wrong [ __ ] and
that's you
mistaken identity
[Laughter]
sorry i had
who would they mistaken identity with
because
i'm a six foot ginger like why would you
oh my gosh
this is the worst part is really
effective too um just saying
i was thinking about buying that the
other day i've never lived
by myself
before now
wait what i've never lived by myself
before now
yeah so i've never thought about a lot
of this stuff but i i do have a lot of
neighbors that are cool
i have a creepy male name
um
how creepy
you should put one of those baths and i
heard that
you can even do a rod just do you have
like a sliding door no i might they
wouldn't be able to unlock my door and
the the glasses
no way the locks here are good like can
they take the door off and hold it
you're like oh [ __ ]
because that's not hard
the door off the hand the opposite side
yeah you know where there's like the
hinge thing you have a hard time it's
like thick like it's like bolted
it's
i'm just saying
like it [ __ ] blew me away
my gosh i can pick a lock
not very good at it
i have done it
oh my god
wait we've gotten so off topic i'm not
doing a good job
um
wait no we're talking about the egg
guys send in super chats for her
yeah oh my gosh wait
this is by far the most terrifying asmr
it's not asmr
who's in this chat right now
it's always
it's always people looking to get
offended
well there's a lot how many people are
watching
40 almost
okay hold on
oh i'm looking at
my black ops oh my gosh did you see the
live i did did you see the show at all
no
it was pretty decent actually wait what
the one girl i saw it with the one girl
with um
i did it
yesterday night
sorry hold on my laptop's on
sorry if you heard that
oh no i didn't hear it okay keep going
but oh my gosh it was crazy i had this
one girl that was on i had the biggest
debate with her
about masculine and feminine yeah and i
was like pulling teeth because she was
saying like why does those type of
clothes have to be matte like why do
paint like basketball clothes have to be
masculine
i always feel like a giant i have
basketball shorts on yeah i'm like i
wear them
i'm not like
i'm like
i'm like
a dress is feminine and then she was
arguing with me i'm like why are we this
is like pulling if a man is in a dress
we're questioning it
um
is it true that gabby is pregnant no
she's not pregnant i'm
my friend that was on that she she's
like we're friends but she's the
opposite of me and everything she
believes
so she'll come on this is the girl
i don't know
what
is this um the one you're talking about
yeah the one that i was facetiming with
okay
okay caps
tell me more
no she's cool we just like don't agree
on anything but she's like that's fun
yeah no it's fun that's what the
manuscript is so where they're like why
would you surround yourself with people
that don't agree with you i'm like i
can't um because
yeah i'm like
it's good to have that argument
all right not argument but discourse
whatever you want to call it
i'm not
i'm not you know
here i'm gonna go on
instagram live
what's up
things
i'm so surprised you haven't
like i could give like a laundry list of
stuff that gives giving me the egg and
go do it carry this team
no it'll just be like the most random
things like
a guy
actually it's mostly just getting
physical too soon and like not leaving
me alone about it like i said no
what
no i agree
the
the guy i dated
for like a month
um
yeah what happened to
i mean she gave me so many eggs
you give me so many
like what are the what's the difference
between like an ick and a red flag
i feel like an ick is a small thing
i don't know i think an ick is pretty
big
right
because it makes you repulsed
it's like a red flag i can move past
yeah yeah that's kind of how i would put
it because it's usually not
you know because like for example with
me like you know guys want to sleep with
you like that's part of it
yeah obviously
so it's not like the end of the world
that they try but it's just when they
keep asking and you're like
it's like you know no i haven't
tell me he was in love with me after a
month of dating that's [ __ ]
disgusting
or this guy was telling me how strong
his feelings were for me
and i was like we only dated like we
only like hung out for like two weeks
then i'm wondering
it's trying to get money out of you
you might i love drawing conclusions yes
that's the wrong
wrong [ __ ] let me tell you the guy
tells me he slept with over
50 women i'm like repulsed
remember
i think don't [ __ ] tell me
that's some
rich guy
wait is that the real paul or no no i'm
pretty sure everyone in the chat is just
trolls like the
that's annoying kick him out a real
thumb sapien well i don't know how to
check while i'm on the live but
the moderators
should do it now the clam
the clam thing is like
it's always the same troll they always
have different
i'm going to block him hold on
i told him
no he wasn't
and ended it right then and there
pearl would be the girl to go after no
but i don't have my dad's millions like
i don't
yeah
trying to think
there was something i was gonna say
about oh i did the guys i have sex with
more than 50 people like that gives you
the egg yeah i was seeing a guy that was
like
like a musician
pretty pretty well known
and he told me that and i was like oh
i mean it wasn't time
tell me no i'm not gonna i can tell you
off camera but okay
um
or if a guy says he's a feminist that it
gives me the biggest ick
yeah like i haven't had a guy tell me
that i i think they would know not to
[Music]
no i this was before i was like on
social media as much
yeah high five
sorry
that um
i went on a date with this guy and it
was going so well like the banter was
there everything was there
yeah
and then he tells me he's a male
feminist
and that he
how did i feel about population control
i was like that's a good question
i'm like
i think of the mice experiment
like sir i have nine siblings
how do you think i feel about it
population control or overpopulation or
under
i don't why do they ask you that can you
call him
no because that was a weird story so he
lived in my building that was how he
asked me out okay
this is when i was like
22.
this was in my
um yeah this was
so he we went on a date went on maybe
two dates
um
and
he
this is this is my fault i'm gonna take
this was naive of me to do okay
but i
brought him back to my apartment but i
told him like before i went up i was
like i don't want to like do anything
and guys always think you're like you
know joking or they think you're gonna
do it anyway because a lot of girls do
you know
but it's okay you [ __ ] up yeah yeah i
shouldn't like i was like oh we can like
hang out but
anyways my point is so he was getting
women
yeah so is my fault i shouldn't have did
that but
so when we're at my apartment he's like
pushing it he like again gives me the
biggest ick right yeah you should have
told him
huh
i feel like you repulse me
like i was like okay can you go because
did you leave yeah he did okay that's
good yeah yeah
but anyway so like i clearly didn't want
to go on a date with him again and
especially i'm like aren't you the
feminist aren't you supposed to like
listen when i say no
oh
isn't that your thing like why do you
keep not leaving it alone
anyways
[ __ ] cap
huh
it wasn't though that's what i'm saying
like if it was a cap i would have slept
with him it wasn't a cat no i'm saying
him saying he's a feminist oh the
feminist and that's what
yeah
um
so then
he whatever like apologized whatever and
i just said i didn't want to go out
again and so i saw him for like months
after just like in the laundry room and
the hallway it's like kind of awkward
but you know you move past it right this
is why i don't live in places like that
i keep going
um so then
he
a couple months later
he messages me on facebook and i'm like
that's kind of weird
and he
he's like is this your i guess i dropped
like a card of mine
okay
which makes sense like that wallet was
like it had more cards in it before and
then i took one out so it was like like
yeah and there's only like two doors to
the building
oh that was nice like he's giving it
back to me so i went to go get it and i
and i go there we like talk for a little
bit
and it's cool but i still don't want
anything you know it's just like like i
just want my card
yeah
yeah but it's
yeah and again i shouldn't have sat and
like talked to him for i'm a chit
chatter though i love to chit chat
that's okay and there's nothing no one
to leave and how to say bye
yeah um anyways so i no i did leave
though i did yeah um so then he messages
me and it's like ask basically asking me
out again and i'm like look
i just don't think that's a good idea
like i'm good on that
and
then he messages me back don't ever talk
to me again
yeah those are and i was like okay well
i wanna see screen i wanna see
screenshots what'd you say to him pearl
i might have something's out of this
story i'm sorry no i asked him for kale
that was the part of the tail
yeah it was like the next day
and then i was
like bro i needed kale i was trying to
make kale chips a dude for kale that's
like
asking for salt okay it's a flirting
oh it's flirting oh yeah that's like
dropping the handkerchief i don't know i
just wanted
if you really need a kl
no i'd be like i can go get it no there
was like two other girls in the building
i wanted to ask first
but they were
yeah you know
it's funny though
but i was like oh my god that escalated
so quickly it was like can i have kale
don't ever talk to me again
i was like i thought we were chilling
from yesterday we're like cool
yeah you're not cool
not cool i was looking kale chips
or fire you ever had them
kale chips yeah you do kale chips
and then you smother them in olive oil
and then you put seasoning on it's
really good i just eat it raw
okay i'm you're i hate it i [ __ ] hate
it well do it i'm telling you it's so
good kale chips i i'll look into it yeah
i'll do it
maybe i'll make like chilaquiles with
kale chips have you ever had that
chili's key lace
with an egg on it it's like a mexican
dish
it's fire
you bake it
it's really good i'm serious
that is the whitest thing
i'm learning how to cook i made wings
the other day and
and i gave my door lady and i are best
friends
and i gave her some and
her
fiance
fiance i forgot what they are if they're
dating or married or whatever um
but
he
they're both like this they're so good
i'm like i can cook now yes
killing it i'm a cooker
what kind did you make
um i mixed cayenne
moroccan seasoning and
chicken seasoning
okay
okay
and then i put like butter as i cooked
it in yeah
and what else what was the dish the side
dish as i said i just made wings just
[ __ ] wings
[Music]
[Laughter]
this person said kale is flirting yes
thank you
thank you asking a guy if you have salt
pepper kale something that you don't
have in the apartment
it's flirting if you live in the same
building i think i just didn't know
about anyone else in my building
i never asked anybody like
yo
antarello i'll be back finish rolo's
live yeah dad
yeah no we could actually end the
livestream yeah i gotta do an episode
yeah yeah
thanks for coming on though sorry this
wasn't you know a little better
we weren't popping it's not our past
yeah you know we could
i'll come better next time i swear
me so
okay bye guys subscribe